on the topic of confessionals about
embarrassing moments what's something
about screenwriting that you're almost
embarrassed to admit that took you so
long to figure out me personally that
I'm no good at it the reason that I'm a
teacher and a consultant and a story
doctor is that I my big secret is I
don't enjoy writing screenplays I tried
for a while to do it but it's not my
thing
I poached repayed I'd be in the chips
because I'm a poet that's what I love to
write and I also like to write novels
but years ago the reason I became what I
am is I failed to complete a screenplay
it got huge interest and I realized at
the end of it says I don't like this
form it's just not for me I love
analyzing it
I love understanding how it works I love
helping other people do it but I don't
enjoy sitting down every day and writing
in the screenplay form it's not my thing
I love to doctor and to help other
people do it that's just my thing we all
have our thing so that's my thing so
that's sort of my embarrassing secret is
this is a craft
I adore analyzing and teaching other
people about that I myself don't enjoy
doing that's kind of embarrassing for
somebody who works in this field but
it's the truth and it's sort of been the
the wound that pushed me into deeply
understanding it because I did so much
want to understand how it worked because
I thought that would be the way in for
me to really do it well but it turns out
it didn't give me great pleasure to
actually work in this form how long did
it take you to figure this out well I
started really story doctoring about 13
years ago and that's after this big
failure - I had a I had a story idea
that got enormous interest and it was
well we're on our way this is this is
what this is the dream and then I
couldn't complete it and then I started
and so I had crashed and burned and then
I then I started thinking I couldn't I
finish it
what is how does story really work and
as I started looking at our story worked
I understood this is my passion I want
to sort of I want to understand it so I
can show other people how it works and
how to do it
but I don't enjoy doing it and that was
a big that took like three or four years
to really just sort of myself but all
the time I was starting to get great joy
from helping other people with their
scripts and then as I said I've read
over 7,000 scripts so I started I knew
what these patterns where I developed
this story this idea this analytical
tool called the BMOC that everyone
started to love and it's a way of
writing around a an insight about your
hero which is about the wound and as I
started doing this I got hired by more
and more people and I just began really
getting passionate about helping them
understand and bring to to their story
what I'd learned about great story all
great hits story and that became sort of
my passion I still write poetry when you
say you weren't interested in the form
was it also sitting at the computer
alone and being sort of your own
taskmaster no I'm good alone it was look
screenwriting is a little bit like doing
chemistry it's it's or math or haikus
let's call it because I'm a poet I don't
know if you know what a haiku is it's a
very particular form you have to have
certain number syllables in this line
certain in this lesson
that's what screenwriting is like so
you've got to learn this pattern it's
very precise it's not like writing a
novel although I teach that too and boy
if you want to be freeform and not worry
so much write a novel although you still
need that character change but a
screenplay is very particular and
television which is what I do more now
than tea or the movies because TV is
where so much great creative stuff is
happening today he's even more
regimented right even though I'm cable
it's getting you can tell a story now in
double hours one of my clients got
enough from a producer I've never heard
before which was can you make the pilot
longer but even so even though
television is revolutionary
revolutionising the way we tell stories
in a Jacobian way getting longer and
longer like the Russian novel the 19th
century and that's why you know it's
great there's still this ABCDEF plot
structure that's very specific that you
must do that even the hippest guys like
Vince Gilligan have to use in Breaking
Bad this plot structure is rigorous so
that i chafed at that I didn't like I
don't want it I don't want to have to
have a second act where all this happens
nope that's not for me I just I'm stupid
rebel at heart so the forum was so
precise that for me I just I didn't
enjoy fitting my vision into it even
though I knew how to do it didn't enjoy
it just not my thing but I love helping
other people do it and I love studying
how it works and how it changes and it's
changing all the time my god in the last
three years
movies have changed enormous ly you
can't talk about things like 30-60-90
anymore movies are shorter the studio's
have taken over with their superheroes
that's a whole different discipline I
haven't talked to you about but it's a
particular discipline and it's not it
doesn't give me pleasure to do that I
forgot the question but anyway do you
remember the day that you had did you
have like an aha moment and you know
scripts pages went flying and said this
is it
I knew when I had this big insight about
how all great movies are structured I
knew no one else had ever discovered
that that was my equal in c-squared
moment because this this this insight I
had helped so many writers and it became
sort of a central thing I still talk
about today it's there's four points in
every movie story when a hero's asked to
change when a hero's core wound is is
put to the test and that pattern is
there virtually from everything from
Star Wars took to pulp fiction and when
I discovered that it was like wow this
is this is cool this this I can give to
riders this and it helps writers
enormous Lee this this rhythm this
pattern every great story has it and I
don't think anybody really discovered it
before so that moment was when I thought
you know I
just get that and that's kind of what
I'm writing a book right now about and
that's helped a lot of writers so that
was the insight that really made me
realize this is for me helping people
understand how to tell their story in
this rhythm and it works for television
too
you